[Music]
this is a National
Emergency Detonator
[Music]
charged we're in the race against the
Nazis and I know what it
means if the Nazis have a
bomb they have a 12-month Head Start 18
how could you possibly know
that we've got one
hope all America's industrial might and
scientific innovation connected here
secret
laboratory keep everyone there until
it's
done let's go recruit some scientists
build a town build it fast we don't let
scientists bring their families we'll
never get the
best why would we go to the middle of
nowhere for who knows how
long why why how about because this is
the most important thing to ever happen
in the history of the
world you're the great improviser but
this you can't do in your head are we
saying there's a chance that when we
push that button we destroy the world
chances are near
zero near zero what do you want from
Theory alone zero would be
[Music]
nice this is a matter of life and
death I can perform this
miracle World War II would be over our
boys would come
home
that's happening isn't
it
world but remember this
day our work here will ensure a peace
mankind is never
see until somebody builds a bigger
Ro you are the man who gave them the
power to dest destroy
themselves and the world is not
prepared
4 3 Truman needs to know what's next 2
what's next
one
whose land is
this my
land well well well our war hero has
arrived you made a good choice calling
back here say are the finest wealthiest
and most beautiful people on God's Earth
yeah it's smart
everybody they have the same who gets
the
oil son I got a question you like women
that's my
weakness
well we mix these families together and
that estate money flows the right
direction it'll come to us
SOI that's how you are I don't know what
you said but it must have been Indian
for handsome
[Music]
devil why did you come
here I work with my uncle you scared of
him
oh he's a he's the nicest man in the
world the old sieg B time is over we got
to take back control of our
home I was sent down from Washington DC
to see about these
murders we have so many deaths we've
lost count this just bad luck seems more
like an epidemic than bad luck to
me those S is dying by the enemy do not
let them die
alone evil surrounds my
heart you going to pick a
side I don't even know if you loved me
anymore of course I love you and kill
these men who killed my
family did your wife say who she was
most afraid
[Applause]
of
don't do something you're going to
regret for the rest of your
[Music]
life I ain't got nothing but
regret how that make you
feel giving a child is
[Music]
freedom so
good you have been at this for 12 years
my country tears of
[Music]
the why are you doing
it cuz God's children are not for
sell it is the fastest growing
International crime Network that the
world has ever
seen for Homeland Security you know we
can't go off rescuing Honduran kids in
columia this job tears you to pieces
and and this is my one chance to put
those pieces back
together somehow you have failed to
bring me one real world
lead it's over Tim close up and come
back
home so you quit your job and you go and
rescue those
[Music]
kids south of that is all Rebel
territory no one goes in don't
shot but if this was your
[Music]
daughter so she's
gone
let
[Music]
freom hear
that that's the sound of
[Music]
Freedom give thanks to
God
the Lord is with
us what can a mere man do to
me Papa I will come back to
you you walk the
earth because I let
you I'm your God now
slaves are
free we must get to Batton Rouge through
this
one M's Army is
there there are many ways to die in a
swamp
[Music]
I must get to my
family what if he don't come
back your papa is going to be back do
not ever stop believing that she's
persistent running hiding surviving
[Music]
I fight
them they beat
me they whip
me they break the
bones in my
body more times than I can
come but they
never never break
[Music]
me
General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a
r I'm not built like other men
generals GED in their
masses move along now those in power
only see me as a br unfit for higher
office just like witches at
black but I follow in the footsteps of
Alexander the Great and
Caesar evil mind destru if you look down
you'll see a
surprise once you see it you'll always
want it s death
construction I must warn you I will not
lead a second of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
head
where
burning you want to be great no you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without This
Vermin whose country are we
in
mine
so what's your big goal dream I want to
be an
[Music]
astronaut oh my God you're
serious
okay I wanted this for almost 30
years every decision I've made I've made
with the Space Program in
mind who the hell are you I'm Jose
Hernandez sir I'm an engineer you're the
new guy right that third floor men's
room needs toilet paper own to space
it's a stupid dream last 10 candidates
were chosen from
12962 applicants it's never going to
happen those people who got into the
program what do they have that you
don't they have skills that I don't
have it's taken them years to get where
they are but there's no
[Music]
guarantee I know this is hard on
everybody my body hurts I can't sleep I
know I can make this
work
over the last 10 years I've applied to
the Space Program 12 times and I've been
on the verge of giving up after each and
every rejection but you know what sir
here I am so you could turn me down
again but rest assured I'll be standing
here again in a
year we grew up watching our people make
sacrifices it's on us
now tenacity is a super
power this may not be your future it
will always be your past who better to
leave this planet and dive into the
unknown
than a migrant Farm worker 5 4 3
2 you're not crying are you pie no no no
no no no some dirt got into my
eye I think what we have here in
Hollywood is high Arts it's party time
[Applause]
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you
go I always want to be part of something
bigger yes let's
go something that last that means
[Applause]
something you know when I first moved La
I got your face touch you know what the
signs on all the doors readed no actors
are dogs
allowed I changed that morning good job
for you I'll do anything that's the
jackass they said to screw
us this [__] is stealing the scene
right from under me she's icing her
nipples till they Park up through her
dress I ain't icing my nipples this is
natural what do you say we com in for my
closeup
[Music]
now what are your thoughts for the
future shouldn't stand in the way of
progress is this going to be what it's
going to
be here's the
twist
wa the girl seems nice she is she has no
idea what's
next there's a new sensibility now
people care about
morals I've never done nothing that
disappoint people in my whole life but I
made it on my terms not
theirs
we are going to be more than they ever
bargain
for what I do means
something it's pick out the
vi
and I'm going to
[Music]
bed I'm Clarence I'm not a man without
fault I played the cards I was
de Clans in spite of your selfish ways
there is a beautiful soul in there yeah
somewhere it's him Jesus of
Nazareth you can't even buy Power like
that I want to be like that in 10
[Music]
years I want to be like that
now knowledge is stronger than
Bel
plans you need the Miracles I have a
plan I can see I can
see God sent me to deliver his message
Mah I am your new
Messiah BL a swne stop
that y God is a
my see for yourselves there is no
Messiah parents if you be so kind to
walk on
water
damn
looks
[Music]
go
there is only one question that
matters do you swear on your
life that what you say is
true my father told me my life will be
blessed with Good
Fortune I'm
married I was a good
wife and then was judged and shamed by
my
[Applause]
country I say before all of
you I spoke the
[Music]
truth a most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
shakri entered our
home he attacked me the accusation is
false I am telling the truth the truth
does not matter there is only the power
of
men this should be settled quietly I'm
innocent I request a duel to the death
if you lose your wife would suffer dire
consequences
one of us has lied let us let God
decide you do not believe
me I am risking my life for you you are
risking my life so you can save your
pride the
penalty for bearing false witness
is that you are to be burned
alive I will not be
[Applause]
silent an evil is
coming that threatens Our
Kingdom our
freedom but we have a
weapon they are not prepared
[Music]
for my king the Europeans wish to
conquer
us they will not stop into the whole of
Africa is
this we must fight
back for our
people H you asking me to take them to
[Applause]
war some things are worth fighting
for you are called to join the King's
Garden no Kingdom in all of Africa
shares this privilege train hard fight
harder
we fear no
one and we fear no
pain I offer you a
choice fight or we
die
that
that that that blood line on the line
Ready for War where
you
to be a warrior you must kill your
te we are the Spear of
Victory we are the blade of
[Music]
Freedom we are the
homet
don't up
take
my Carl I don't know what you think
you're doing excuse me
hello got a dead white man in a
box not even a casket doesn't even have
a top on it in a pine box of old wood
who do you think's going to get in
trouble
here do me a favor try to be
optimistic
you don't get here without things
starting a long time
[Music]
ago so two soldiers and a nurse found
ourselves
in
Amsterdam we formed a pact and we swore
to protect each other no matter
what we found ourselves in a situation
where we're accused of killing someone
which is not
true you and Woodman fled the seene the
killer pointed at us we didn't do
anything why would you possibly think
that was us well there's not too many
people that fit the description of a
doctor looking for his eye on the ground
with his black Attorney Columbia Law
School we need someone to help us to
find the truth my friend was
killed because of something monstrous
that he had seen
this is all turning out to be a lot
larger than any of
us you're going to have to take my lead
getting out of this I had to stab a guy
I had to hit a lady with a brick one
time what it's a long story but with you
two it'll be a
cakewalk these are dangerous times you
be
careful I'm about to do something that
could cost me my
life the cuckoo is in the nest and the
cuckoo is about to be
trapped cuckoo
[Music]
this is one of the finest Innovations
from Zurich it removes all pain guys
like me we have to turn to booze the
morphine and that can lead to addiction
oh that's fast that is
advaned
change
World in 5 weeks 100,000 British forces
will strike Sicily's Southern
Shore unfortunately the Nazis know have
our
intentions so we're going to play a
humiliating trick on
Hitler we have to convince Germany that
our Target is Greece the plan begins in
Spain where the corpse will wash up on
shore bearing classified letters
a corpse carrying fake
documents given the fascist notebook
there we could quite literally float the
documents right into enemy
hands prime minister that's too big a
risk the fate of the world is at stake
the plan is highly implausible so when
can it be ready well what say we start
with the easy part and find ourselves a
corpse thing is the Chon scrutinizer
every detail of our fallen man where are
his
legs he must be as real as your eye he
would carry a letter from his wife
professing her deep love for him very
good and he would carry her photograph
my contribution to the mission for a
seat at the
table although what if the autopsy
reveals he didn't die of drowning or if
the briefcases return to us without the
Germans seeing its
contents Charles why on Earth do you
keep poking holes in our plan I'm
preemptively
poking success ESS depends on Guiding
the papers into Hitler's
hands the nightmare marching this way is
only too real and the Spanish would let
the Germans anywhere near our briefcase
we are in the dark if the enemy is
waiting for us on those beaches history
herself will avert her eyes from the
slaughter I may
vomit I may vomit with
you in stories of War there is that
which is seen and that which is
hidden in God's name Fleming what are
you
writing spy
story in the hidden War the truth is
protected by a bodyguard of
Lies its soldiers unseen pray its Heroes
unsan this is our
war dear
Edith you foxy ass old
[__] carry
on you really are a trixy old
[__] and you're a sad stinky [__] in
the end I think it's just
jealousy I think we know who it is love
my neighbor and I tried but I get you in
the ball she's heus Edith I didn't do it
I believe you may be charging an
innocent a woman police officer oh look
Flying Pig I've got a daughter at home
why would I risk it all you want [__]
in the nose holes you old beetle beetle
right if you meddle in my case these
will be on your
wrists in prison Rose may find some
Kindred Spirits in prison no no not the
murders or the rapists I'm thinking more
the drunks and the que maybe just trying
to find a bright
side hey you d old [__] slippery old
[__]
Dodger why would I send a letter when I
can just say
it I probably say that you look like
[__] Queen Victoria shoved a [__]
netop or [__] [__] I don't know you
s come and [__] and the cakes you make
look like they fall out some [__] sh
[__] [__]
better I have a
planation will catch them in the
ACT what would your husband think my
husband isn't alive so he's not thinking
a great
deal I like her Rose I hate
her you don't like the idea of me living
this house do you I'm going to lose her
we're not standing for it I've had one
now
everyone is going to
know it's
German
I can
[Music]
all